next week I sing in choir。
when we stand around the tree。
I've never missed a Christmas。
from 2010 to 23。
hello 大家好 我是蕾希。
我是先欢迎来到令皮西镜。
这是一档有两位文化行业从业者。
共同主持的波克
我们是同行 同事 同龄 同乡。
也是酒店一起令皮西镜的老友。
在这档波克
我们将从当代人的生活。
与工作中的共鸣出发。
直面困局打开新的局面。
欢迎大家来到我们新一期的节目。
那熟悉令皮西镜的天中。
肯定知道我们通常一开始。
都会分享本期选题的契机。
那它往往会很具体。
比如说上上期关于NPD的呢？
它是源于我一次和一位。
疑似NPD患者的攻击晚餐的经历。
再比如第55期聊恐惧的。
更是具体到来自我在体检。
抽血时候产生的感悟。
那这次的主题
大家从标题也看到了。
是关于Think Big的。
其实并没有特别具体的契机。
而是一种长时间的磨磨糊糊的感觉。
那就是好像过往的几年。
我一直处于一个
就是没有那么的感想感做。
甚至就是没有意识到。
我需要感想感做的状态。
但是就是这一年以来。
我就有种突然被点醒了的感觉。
就是有点变得不安于现状了。
对很多事情也多了一份渴求。
也强烈的希望能够挖掘自己的更多潜力。
那我其实有点不知道。
这种转变是从哪里来的。
希望通过今天这期节目。
能和大家一起速速圆。
希望这期能给你一点大安吧？
我其实也是有点理解你说的这种。
突然好像不太安于现状的感受。
那最直观的其实就是。
我之前从来没有想过。
有一天能把一项运动技能变成。
真的一份非常妥妥当当的职业。
那我觉得这一切实现的前提。
真的是首先你得感想。
觉得自己可以那样做。
我想起来之前
跟我的coach聊天的时候。
他问过我一个问题说。
我又没有想过自己这一生的mission。
也就是我的使命是什么？
这么大的命题
是他不是什么你要聊职业规划。
或者有定一个五年十年目标之类的。
而是在让我去想
我愿意终生持续追求的这样的一个事业。
或者说终极理想是什么？
我那个时候真的是想了好久。
都没有得出一个自己满意的答案。
当时其实让我还觉得挺懊恼的。
就会觉得好像自己怎么都想不清楚。
但现在我倒觉得
现在还好才30多岁。
就想这事其实也不算太晚。
之前会觉得
讨论什么人生的意义。
人生的愿景
包括使命这样的词。
是特别空的
会觉得离现实是很远不落地。
但其实从
之前我跟coach聊天的这个问题。
这个方向来想的话。
我觉得是因为
我们其实很少花时间去想这类问题。
所以才会让它显得离我们那么的远。
所以这期我和来西去聊。
think big这个话题的时候。
我觉得其实也是想把我们自己的。
思考尺度再放的大一点吧？
毕竟我们其实都挺擅长去关注具体的。
也很关注下一步是什么？
就说白了
我觉得我们挺擅长think small的。
但这确实也比较容易让我们迷失在。
任务里面
而不是专注在说
往前看看我们更大的方向是什么？
是
但我还是很怀疑说。
一生的mission真的能靠想来想清楚吗？
我目前是没有答案的。
我觉得可能更多是不是还是得靠一步一步的。
行动来检验
而且就是
刚才你提到说咱俩聊think big这个话题。
说实话对于这个话题。
我反正是有点犹豫的。
我知道CNN其实也有点。
因为我们都会有点担心说。
这期会聊得太成功学了。
太打击学了
而现在社会其实并不需要这些。
假大空的东西吧？
但我相信就是有很多人和我一样。
会好奇说一个人怎么样能记。
敢想敢做
又不被这种必须成功的愿景来绑架。
为了回答这个问题。
我们这期也按图所记的一篇外刊。
和大家一起一个另辟西境的角度。
来看待敢想敢做这件事情。
读了之后我会觉得。
相比设立一个宏大的目标。
它只是说给大脑植入一个理想的途径。
从而引导自己往向往的生活。
和向往的自己不断靠近。
对 那刚才莱希提到了。
我们每月一期的外刊栏目又来了。
是的 预视不决找外刊。
而且这次的来源
依然还是来自我们。
经常会去分享的平台medium。
感觉我们真的应该为medium。
专门开一个专栏
是的 后面想一想。
那这次我们选的这篇文章。
叫做The Five Life Long Lessons。
From The Magic of Thinking Big。
by David Schwartz。
从大卫施瓦茲的
《勇于思考的魔力》这本书中。
学到的五个受用一生的人生启发。
作者是妮娜三穗
那从这篇文章的标题。
就看得出妮娜的写作灵感。
来自这本叫做
《勇于思考的魔力》的书。
那这是一本出版于1959年的。
经典唱销书
时间非常久远了
作者是美国作家兼商业。
教育家
大卫施瓦茲
那我还特意去豆瓣乡。
看一下这本书的平分。
还挺高的
8.5分
只不过是
只有33个人读过。
希望我们这期播了能多俩。
起码会多咱们两个人。
也不一定
我其实还没有开始读这本书。
我也没有
但确实虽然我们
现在在豆瓣乡看
只有30多个人读过。
但在当时的那个年代。
这本书可以说是被很多人。
视为个人成长领域的经典。
它影响了很多
创业者 企业家
包括一些职场的人群。
那这本书的核心关联。
其实很简单
就是说
一个人的成就
很多时候不需先被能力限制的。
而是先被思维限制的。
当然我们现在去听起来。
会觉得
这个关联好像也没有什么稀奇的。
包括我们这篇外刊的作者。
妮娜在刚开始读这本书的时候。
她其实也没有抱太大的期望。
觉得她可能又是一本。
充满成功学的老书。
但她读完整本书之后。
却发现里面其实有很多。
常见的道理是
我们经常听
但是实践起来并不简单的。
所以她从这本书里面。
体验出了五个让她自己。
印象最深刻的人生启发。
从如何看待自己
到如何面对他人
包括自己的梦想
行动还有外界的评价这些。
虽然都是一些非常。
看似很简单的道理。
但其实延展开
我觉得还是依然非常适合。
帮助我们
现在去用来借鉴
看看怎么在这个时代。
去拓展自己的思维吧？
因为后面我们会一展开。
这五个观点
这里就不细说了
希望到时候的分享。
能够对大家还是有。
一点点帮助的
那我来介绍一下
这篇文章的作者
Nina Semsik。
就像前面说的
就是虽然我们今天。
聊的这篇文章
可能会有一点
成功学的感觉
但是Nina她本人。
不是一个那种
典型的成功学博主。
反而会是一个
就是精力和身份
都很杂柔的人
她做过写作者
编辑 SCU顾问。
也教过瑜伽
然后做插画和讨意。
更特别的是
就在搬回纽约之前。
她还曾经是
美国陆军的
一名情报军官
然后我还在她的
那个自我介绍里头。
看到一个特别
可爱的标签
叫做Library Lovers。
就是很爱图书馆的人。
对 这个点
我和新人
肯定都非常有共鸣。
因为我觉得就是
喜欢图书馆的人
肯定不会是
带着一种很
功利的目的
去读书的
也不是为了
显得很有文化
而是真的很享受
那种沉浸在
知识里头的感觉
随着这篇文章
它虽然聊的是
一本成功学的经典。
但它写出来
没有那么的激血
而更像是一个
就是长期和书
相处的人那样
带着一种
筛选 怀疑
和重新理解的能力。
在旧书里头
减出几个
今天还能用的
生活提醒
是的
尤其是我在文章中。
有看到
Nina提到自己。
不再只是梦想
成为一名瑜伽老师。
而是开始给这个梦想。
设立一个目标
并真的开始做到之后。
我当时还觉得
供情道了
对 真的有供情道。
那后面
我们话不多说
开始进入这篇
来看中
关于五个观点的
分享吧？
那接下来
我们都进入文章中。
提到的第一点
叫做BeHuman。
我觉得可以
就是简单
把它翻译成
做个人吧？
主要是在说
与其把别人
当成帮助自己
成功的工具
不如真诚的
尊重理解和鼓励别人。
说实话
看完这部分
我是有点
云里污吏的
就是感觉鸡汤有余。
然后和Sink Big的关系不足。
但是呢？
他提到一个
很有趣的心理学概念。
我觉得还是值得分享的。
叫做皮哥马利翁效应。
指的呢？
是人们被富裕高期望之后。
表现得更好的心理现象。
他呢是来自一个
著名的实验
就是研究人员随机。
挑出了一批学生
却告诉老师说
这个是未来
最有潜力的一群孩子。
那一年之后
这群孩子的成绩
真的明显提高了
后来发现就是改变。
他们的并不是智商。
而是老师相信他们。
能够做到
于是呢就给予了
更多的鼓励啊？
耐心啊和机会
我当时看到这块呢？
会有点理解这一部分的用意。
就是虽然皮哥马利翁效应。
他讲的是
我们对别人的期待。
但是反过来也是一样的。
就是当别人
对我们展现出期待。
或者自己
对自己产生期待
那我们可能也会活成。
期待中的样子
那之所以作者把这个。
比human放到第一条。
我理解也是在表达说。
think big不是吧？
目标想的很大
而是不要过早的
给自己设定这个上限。
我觉得其实就是
对自己不断降低期待。
是一件还挺普遍的事情吧？
尤其是在当下
那20出头的时候。
我们总会觉得说
自己未来
肯定会成就一番大事业。
但是呢当10年过去之后。
还是牛马一枚
我们相对于相信说。
自己必然会大气完成。
可能更普遍的选择。
就是会接受自己的平凡。
甚至平庸
从而走上这个人生的下坡路。
这个呢就是一种
很典型的
互相的皮根马里翁效应。
也是think big的天底。
就是我看完这部分的感受。
跟你还挺像的
会觉得这个bhuman。
跟think big的关系。
到底是什么？
尤其是作者在开头。
其实就举了一个
看起来非常随机的。
一个例子
是 采摘
对 他去农场采摘的一个故事。
说他自己在采摘结账的时候呢？
发现后面没人排队。
且修营员也就是农场主。
正在对自己微笑
那他就没有像往常一样。
匆忙交钱走人
而是选择跟农场主。
闲聊了起来
而这件事
带给他的感受是
无论你身处
在什么样的位置上。
都要给予他人
以信任和耐心
这个确实
就是诈一听
还挺云理物理的
就开头也不讲
怎么think big。
去设立你的目标
而是先去讲
你要怎么去对待别人。
我其实最开始在跟来西去。
对提纲的时候
我们两个人都属于。
可能想要把这部分跳过。
但后面我再想说
他如果把这个放在。
第一部分
是不是代表这个还挺重要的。
对 我就很刻意的去理解了一下。
再猜想说
做久是不是想要表达的是说。
你可以think big。
但你不能只顾自己。
你也得包容别人
就可能说你是在一个。
创业的状态
那你就不能觉得那些。
朝久晚午
上班的人
是处在一个安逸的状态。
或者说
你是在坚持读书的。
那么你就觉得那些。
刷短视频的人
就是在浪费时间
就think big这个思维。
不应该让你觉得
自己比别人是更厉害的。
因为那个其实会
变成一种优越感
他反而是能够让你。
越来越意识到
每个人都有自己对。
big这个词的理解。
就你不会去拿自己的。
标准去客量别人
那这么一想
我觉得当然是很刻意的。
就be a woman。
作为think big的第一站。
确实是一个地基的存在。
就确保你的价值观。
和你的出发目的
不是为了去彰显自己。
而是真的为了一个自己。
非常渴望的方向去做努力。
不知道刚刚聊的第一部分。
包括尤其是那个
皮革马利翁效应的时候。
大家会不会想到
很多现在的流行词。
比如说像是
吸引力法则
然后比如我们之前。
聊过的显化
反正我自己读到那的时候。
脑子里第一时间冒出来的。
就是那些词
而文章的第二部分。
它的标题叫做
Thinking is possible makes it so。
就可以翻译成
相信就会实现
就更有玄学那味了。
但我觉得就是和
新想试诚的区别在于说。
这块讲的呢？
是一种行动导向的信念。
作者所强调的是
就是当一个人
相信一件事情
会有可能的时候
那他的行为模式
也会随之发生改变。
会更愿意去尝试
愿意去争取
也更容易坚持下去。
这里的逻辑是不一样的。
就是不是因为事情。
做不到
所以我们不去做
而是因为我们
先认定做不到
所以很多事情
才真的没有发生
那聊到这的时候
我的记忆其实有点闪。
回到十年前
就是当时毕业求职的时候。
我没有选择海投
因为我的Dream Company。
非常的清晰
于是我就找到
那个老板的联系方式。
给他发了个邮件
没想到还真的得到了。
回复和面试的机会。
而且来了之后
一呆就是十年到现在。
但我觉得其实也有点。
讽刺的是
这个开局非常的敢想敢做。
而想给他划上结局。
却默默积极迟迟没有下手。
我们好像就是在
年纪轻轻的时候
都去被那种
打引号的一响天开的本能。
那年纪大了
就会变得有点为手为脚。
即便敢想
但却没有那么敢做。
的确是这样
你说这个让我想到。
有一个理论吧？
不是说人对世界的认知。
其实大概会有
四个层次
分别是
你不知道自己不知道。
你知道自己不知道。
还有知道自己知道。
以及不知道自己知道。
那其实我觉得
很像那个什么？
帅而不自知
美而不自知的那个。
确实有点那个意思。
大家可以在
听到这一部分的时候。
再导回来对应一下。
我觉得很多人
年轻的时候
其实就是会处在
第一个阶段
就你不知道自己不知道。
所以因为你不知道。
就会特别的敢嘛？
不管是
换工作
出生牛肚不拍虎的感觉。
就因为你不知道
前面要面临的是什么？
所以你会觉得
做每一个决定
其实都是一个新的开始。
留学也好
搬家
换一个工作
就这些大胆的决定。
我觉得好像
都在第一个阶段
做出来的时候
非常的容易
你不知道困难有多少。
风险有多大
但确实
像刚才来西提到的。
当我们成长到一定年龄之后。
我们就会进入到那个。
挺有自知之明的阶段了。
也就是知道自己
不知道
自己的能力边界在哪。
然后也知道
现实是远比我们
想象中是复杂的
所以在做每一个决定的时候。
都会先去想
它的风险
它的成本
包括它失败的可能性。
就总觉得会
需要给自己留一点退路。
当然
我觉得在现在的这个时代。
需要谨慎一点
保守一点
肯定不是一个坏事。
但我会觉得
我们很多人都挺喜欢。
或者习惯停留在这个阶段。
然后就不继续往下走了。
而在这部分
作者所说的
Thinking is possible to make it so。
其实就是推动我们。
走到下一步的结发。
不光是相信就能实现。
而是
你要想一想
你选择去相信什么？
也挺重要的
我们长大之后
其实是很容易根据。
自己现有的能力
去制定目标的
因为这样最安全
也最现实
但929制这样的目标。
可能
它就不能叫目标了。
因为它其实从设立一开始。
就完全在你的能力范围之内。
你是够得到的
所以它其实更像是一种计划。
如果从 think big 的角度来说。
目标的意义
肯定不只是可实现的。
它应该是带一点点引领性。
甚至是有一些超越性的。
它有点足够大的
让今天目前
你是需要
也感觉好像垫一点脚。
还费点劲
还有点够不到
不得不再成长一下。
才能接住它
我觉得可能在那个阶段。
我们才真的能够
换一个思维
或者说
换一个角度
重新看一下
我们现在所接触的这些东西。
是
在这个部分
作者Nina
她还现身说法了一下。
也就是刚才新
特别提到的
就是关于她
成为瑜伽老师的那个例子。
就是她
原本是一直希望自己有一天。
能成为一名瑜伽老师。
但这个其实对她来说。
只是一个很模糊的愿望。
直到她把这个希望成为。
变成了我要在今年年底前。
成为
事情就开始发生了变化。
她首先是开始主动寻找。
各种可能性
比如说每天凌晨
她4点钟就起床
在去部队之前
会先去CrossFit的健身房。
教瑜伽
每周也会给
军营里头的战友上课。
周末还会去到
当地的工作室带课。
她发现说
真正改变的不是外部条件。
而就是自己的思维方式。
从我希望这件事情发生。
变成了我要想办法让她发生。
听着就是有点卷
但我觉得这种把问题。
从能不能做到改成。
如果能做到我该怎么做的思维。
其实是用于我们每个人的。
在这我也想再补充一个小例子。
就来自我们现在
不是在做一个品牌吗？
这个品牌的产品负责人。
因为我们所研发的产品。
就是对于同一品类的。
上线有产品来说
其实会有一些创新的部分。
所以当和供应商工厂沟通的时候。
当他提出他的设想。
比如说这种材质能不能做。
压磨塑形那种形态。
能不能打孔等细节问题的时候。
对方通常会秒回一个不行。
但是我们这个产品负责人。
他就是有一种我很佩服的。
那种打破杀锅问到底的精神。
他会继续追问说
为什么不行
为什么做不到
技术难点到底在哪里。
我们是否有办法
能绕过这个难点达成目的。
而很神奇的是
就是在这样一连串拆解。
问题的灵魂考问之下。
很多原本的难题
确实因人而解了
因此我觉得就是
很多时候不可能做不到。
都是一种
未经验证的自我判断吧？
就是一种懒惰的惯性。
或者是
也可以说是避免失败。
和丢脸的托词
就像那句话说的万事开头难。
我觉得当完成了
就是从觉得一件事情。
是不可能的
到可能的
这个开头之后
后面的很多问题
都可以通过
实际的行动来一一化解。
非常同意
而且说来也巧
在定了我们这期
聊Sink Big之后。
我才想起来
我家属他们公司的。
Principal里面。
其中一条就是Sink Big。
就来自他们
那个平台
比较官方的一个产数。
我还专门搜了一下。
是说局限性的思考。
会带来局限性的结果。
这点其实跟你
刚才所说的
我觉得还挺顺应的。
你的思维上的多行。
确实是会把你困在。
问题之中的
然后我就很好玩
我就问了一下
我家属他们一般
内部都是怎么去理解。
Sink Big这回事的。
然后他的回答
就非常的赤裸和直接说。
这个不就是话柄吗？
也没错
是我在网上
也看到很多
他们公司的员工
在吐槽企业文化
这种环境里面
其实很难真正做到。
Sink Big。
因为首先你能看到的。
Picture
就是你的那个
能看到的世界就很小。
所以其实很难要求。
每一个人都能站在。
整个公司的那个角度。
去思考问题
对于一个组织来讲。
Sink Big确实很容易变成。
一句口号
因为真正决定方向的人。
只有少数
你无论怎么努力
怎么相信
这个结果其实
我觉得并不会因为你个人。
而改变多少
但是对于个人来讲。
我觉得Sink Big跟。
在企业里面很不一样的是。
它其实不是说给别人听的。
比如今天告诉自己说。
我想成为一个什么样的人。
做一个什么样的作品。
或者想过一个什么样的生活。
这件事其实
没有其他人会参与。
也没有其他人帮你去实现。
你其实是要自己去。
计划这件事情的
所以Sink Big。
其实这个初衷
我觉得对于个人来讲。
它其实会更纯粹许多。
因为这个目标它最终。
会不会成真
就真的取决于你能够为。
这个目标去付出多少努力。
所以我觉得聊到
Sink Big这个话题的时候。
可能我们在网上搜索的时候。
会看到都是在一个。
职业语境下去讨论这个话题。
所以我觉得可以把它放在一个。
跟个人的角度去想一想。
你自己的生活
或者说你个人的成长路径里面。
你可以怎么把它
做得更大更逼个一点。
不得不说你对你
家属公司的这个Principle的理解。
比他要深刻的多
已经有播客了
是第二点我们展开还蛮多的。
接下来就进入
全文我最拍大腿认同的。
第三部分了
它标题叫做
Ignore the Haters。
然后我想先给大家念一段。
文中的原话
它说
If someone is a Donner。
Gossiper they say it。
We're just playing man。
Ignore them。
那翻译过来
就是说如果一个人。
总是传播负能量
爱八卦
凡事都唱反调
或者就是单纯的刻薄。
那就别理他
这我觉得有几个词。
非常的有意思
欢迎大家给
身边的人对号入座。
第一个叫做Donner。
也就是扫性的
破冷水的
总传播负能量的Sunkie Ball。
第二个是Gossiper。
这个大家就比较熟悉了。
就是那些很爱讲八卦。
班农是非的人
第三个词
我这次也是第一次见。
叫做Nay Sayer。
Nay
它是No的离谕的说法。
意思就是不
那Sayer就是说话的人。
连起来就很好理解了。
就是那些习惯说不。
凡事唱反调
否定别人的人
我觉得这三种人设。
其实也不代表就是坏人。
而是他们可能天生。
就是这种区保守
或者消极的思维模式。
不是说在刻意找别人的词。
对待自己的时候
可能更加的苛刻和极端。
我身边就有非常好的朋友。
经常会把布
或者什么单式挂在嘴边。
但我也很清楚的知道说。
他一些表面上面的。
可以说是质疑吧？
其实是从现实出发。
为我进行更多考量。
怕我把事情想得太容易了。
但我会觉得就是
我们其实就是要把事情。
想得容易一点
他才会真的变容易一点。
没错 特别同意
就像文章里说的
如果你能将80%的时间。
花在积极思考上
哪怕你只是中立思考上。
那其实就是一件
再好不过的事了
像刚才来西
前面提到的几类人群。
我觉得我们身边
应该大家对号入座。
还是挺容易的吧？
有很多爱泼冷水的人。
而且我相信
如果你能够意识到。
身边有很多爱泼冷水的人。
那么你身边一定也会有一些。
在虚寒温暖的人
就像一件事
他无论是多么积极正面。
尤其是互联网
像现在的社交媒体吧？
一定是会听到不一样的声音。
有一些人会告诉你。
千万别这么干
因为他自己就是
被这种事儿耽误的。
那另外一些人
则会告诉你说
他们觉得这件事情。
彻底改变了他们的人生。
是一个特别特别棒的尝试。
就我相信这个时候。
当你看到两个不同的观点。
两个不同的方向的时候。
你应该还是会
想一想
当下自己的处境
你的经验
然后再来做出选择的。
或者至少
你会用一些更客观。
理性的方式去查证一番。
而不是真的直接去。
听由这其中哪一方。
来帮你做这个决定。
当然这个不是说
我们觉得他们
其中哪一方是在撒谎。
或者想存心害人
我觉得那个其实
更多是因为
每一个人其实
大家的人生经验
和生存方式是不一样的。
有的人可能
就是更倾向于
非常的悲观
有的人可能
就是会更乐观一点。
那你可以去借鉴
可以去参考
但我觉得很重要的是。
我们还是要有能力。
去相信自己的
故事版本吧？
还是会跟他们
两个是不一样的
这个我觉得会是
一种 think big吧？
就是你始终愿意相信。
别人走过的路
所到的终点
未必就是你的那个终点。
别人可能遇到的一些。
边界一些坎坷
未必就是你会遇到的。
边界和坎坷
你这个最后的这个金句。
让我想到了
我忘了是哪个采访里头。
就是记者问这个
被采访的人
有没有什么建议
给到年轻人
然后这个人的回答。
那就是少听建议
我觉得说的真的是太妙了。
然后也非常同意
刚才你提到说
就是不论是听到
什么样的声音
最后我们大概率
还是会根据自己的。
经验做出选择
我觉得这也不是说。
周遭的声音都是噪音。
只是就是能验证想法的。
没有真实去行动
说到这好像正好可以。
自然銜接到作者
给出的下一个观点。
是 因为这第四个观点。
刚好就跟行动相关了。
它叫做 one step at a time。
也就是想得大一点。
但还是一步一步的来。
我觉得这点
确实挺关键的
因为 sync big 可能在。
很多人印象中都挺空的。
就代表一直在空想。
或者说一直在聊一些。
非常远大的目标
也是我后来
其实在定这个选题的时候。
会比较担心的
但这部分的内容
我觉得刚好是一个。
非常细化的
非常实践性的一个建议。
那这部分的内容就在说。
真正的 sync big 一定是。
离不开 do small 的。
也就是把一个大的目标。
拆解成一个又一个。
具体的小行动
那比如对于作者
Nina 来讲
如果她要完成一部作品。
那她就知道自己需要。
做下来尽可能多的写作。
就好比如果你要写一本。
二十五万字的小说。
你不能每天都告诉自己说。
我要写一本
二十五万字的小说。
那个大概率
就会让你一下子
被挑战 吓到
然后想要放弃
但如果你只是告诉自己。
今天要写八百字
那就会让你更容易。
开始做这件事情
那关于这一点
其实我自己也有一个。
挺切身的例子
我之前不是在
阅读分享里面
应该我们做
那个阅读总结的时候。
我有提到
我之前有一个习惯。
是会在自己的 calendar 里面。
去 block 一个时间段。
专门去读书嘛？
但我就发现
其实你每天固定
比如说晚上
某一个时间去做一件事情。
还挺难的
因为那个时候
如果我一旦没有开始。
我可能这件事情
我在做下去
就不太可能了
直接放弃
是 特别容易放弃。
然后后来我就把
每晚九点半
阅读两个小时
这个自我约定
变成一个
怎么讲
就是有点像是一个。
更启动感觉的
这样的一个
一个 block 的内容吧？
我会告诉自己说
只要我开始玩手机。
超过半小时了
那我这个时候
就该去读书
一个触发机制
对 这个启动动作。
就变得非常的具体。
而且让我更容易开始。
是真的
而一旦开始了
这个具体的小行动。
就会非常顺利的开展。
所以还是说回来
我觉得 sync big 给的是。
一个方向
而 do small 给的。
其实就是
那个临门一角的路径。
那从方向到路径
我觉得应该就是
最难走的那一步吧？
我甚至觉得有些人。
可能挺擅长 sync big 的。
可能大部分人
都挺擅长 sync big 的。
就是大家可能都会。
坐在一个地方
能想好久
唱响好久
但因为没有办法
做到 do small。
所以才会觉得
去做 sync big 这件事。
是一个
特别空想
然后特别难实践的事情。
还真是
多么痛的领悟
我觉得这点真的很关键。
就是因为聊 sync big。
就是很容易聊得很宏大。
但是你的目标
确实是可以很宏大的。
但是注意力和行动。
又必须小
作者在这还引用了。
一个在读者文摘上的。
一个故事
就是说一位占地记者。
他在二战期间
因为飞机失事
被迫和同行的人
一起跳伞
到缅甸和印度边境的。
丛林里头
他们需要徒步
穿越 140 英里的山地。
才能获救
刚开始
每个人都觉得
这是一个根本
不可能完成的距离。
因为有的人的脚
是被钉子扎伤了
有的人满脚都是血泡。
光是想到
还有一百四十英里要走。
就已经觉得绝望了。
但后来他们改变了想法。
不去想那一百四十英里。
只想着翻过眼前这座山。
走到下一个村庄
那最后
他们真的一步一步。
走出了叢林
这个故事
就是听着
虽然有点那种
语文课本的感觉
但是我觉得还是
很说明问题的
就是当你把注意力。
放回到眼前的下一步。
很多你原本
觉得不可能的事情。
就会慢慢变得可能。
所以完成目标的第一步。
其实是拆解目标
把它拆问到
你觉得第一步
自己可以轻松完成的时候。
就够了
感觉咱俩又立志上了。
希望大家听到这里的时候。
还是觉得有一些
建议是比较使用的。
对 拆起来
好 那终于来到
我们最后一条
也就第五条观点了。
也就是
想得大 更要做得多。
说直白点
就是让你自己忙起来。
那这部分里面
Nina写了一句话。
我觉得还挺有道理的。
她的原话是
当一个人真正忙起来的时候。
她反而会更清楚
什么事情值得做
什么事情可以不做。
因为忙碌
会逼着你学会极致的效率。
也逼着你做取舍
比如做者Nina发现。
一旦自己把各项课程。
任务 兴趣都添加到。
自己的图图list之后。
她的工作效率
就会立马提升
因为工作量的增加。
往往意味着
她需要停止
把时间浪费在那些。
没有意义的事情上。
比如对她来讲
这种无意义的事情。
就包括刷手机和看客种。
随机刷到的扣文
但一旦她把工作
余家教学
还有做的什么志愿活动。
烹饪
包括社交活动
全部都在她的日程里面。
排的满满当当
她就完全不会再有时间。
去浪费在那些
没有意义的时间
黑洞上了
说实话
这个是有让我想到了。
我的一个状态
就是我每次
带着Line的时候。
就那天
我的一天真的是排的满满当当的。
而且我的效率异常的高。
我不是总嘲笑我自己。
说带Line是我的第一生产力。
就我知道这个肯定。
不是什么好的习惯。
但确实当我们觉得。
时间好像还够的时候。
就是会不断给自己留余地。
留退路
但一旦你能够掌握的。
那个资源开始变得有限。
不管这个资源是时间。
还是经历
还是你的注意力
我们反而就会开始认真思考。
说当下我需要真正。
专注在的事情是什么？
就哪件事情是真正重要的。
那我觉得这个
DOOMOR这一条其实就是主动的。
让你把你自己的资源。
变得有限
不管是你的时间
还是你的经历
因为这样你就没有办法。
去无意识的浪费这个资源了。
而是总要想着
我做的每一件事情。
到底值不值得
我去花费我的资源。
这个其实
我觉得应该也是在BigSync了吧？
你再把你的资源
更大更统稠的去想。
然后把他跟
未来的那些东西
连接在一起
是 我觉得这部分。
真的是金句贫出
就除了刚才先念的那句之外。
还有一句我也非常的感同身受。
那作者说
if you want something done。
ask a busy person to do it。
我觉得这个简直就是。
我职业生涯的真实写照。
我觉得之前
就是在节目里头也分享过。
我是会在越忙的时候。
效率越高
甚至会有点享受这种状态。
真是你的人生吧？
我觉得我自己说出来。
都觉得有点变态
然后也有点反常识。
但其实就是
先前面分享的原因。
当你已经处在一个。
很忙碌的状态里头的时候。
那你脑海里头对于。
要做的事情
是有很清晰的规划的。
因此即便这个时候。
你的to do list又新增加了一项。
你也会根据它的难易程度。
在现有的规划当中。
迅速的为它安插一个位置。
为它设定非常清晰的时间安排。
那当完成后
会产生一种爽感
让你更有动力去做下一件事情。
而如果就是你的清单上。
它是一个完全空白的状态。
一是你需要时间热身。
来进入这种做事情的状态。
二是紧迫感的缺失。
也会使得拖延成为常态。
虽然我个人还是挺推崇。
这种忙上加忙的方式的。
但在这我也还是想要。
分享两个警惕吧？
就是第一个是要警惕。
能者多劳的陷阱
我觉得在某种程度上。
我是有点被这种
能者多劳的说辞
绑架过好长一段时间的。
为此也承担了许多。
本来不属于我的工作量。
在别人的工作
越干越轻松的时候。
我却忙上加忙
在职场这点确实很难避免。
因此我觉得就是
大家一定要明确工作的边界。
并且还要敢于说不。
那第二个警惕是警惕瞎忙。
也就是那种忙着忙着。
就是忘了为什么？
开始忙的状态
这个在现在这个一切都。
及时回复
托手可得的AI时代。
我觉得是有其重要的。
为了搭上时代的变车。
我们可能会冲动开启一些事情。
但是如果只是为了跟风而跟风。
到头来很有可能
就是给自己塗加负担。
没错没错
我觉得不知道大家。
有没有概括到
刚才来西说的这种。
忙上加忙的方式
但如果大家真的想要。
健行do more的话。
我觉得还是别
do more work。
还是do more life。
你可以do more exercise。
可以
总之是不要给自己的人生。
去增加更多任务
或者更多你需要去打卡的东西。
而是去增加更多的伪度吧？
包括前面其实我们聊到。
大家在提think big的时候。
经常会觉得这是一个。
在职场里面
非常会被提及的话题。
我觉得最好也在想。
do more这件事情的时候。
也不要把这个场景。
设置在职场
你可以把这个默放在。
你从没有尝试过的。
爱好或者体验开始。
那这些新鲜的体验。
一定从某种程度上。
是能够让你的思维。
突然变得截然不同的。
可能也会更宽广吧？
聊到最后
我想到上周看的一部电影。
非常适合在这期推荐给大家。
那电影的名字
叫做玫瑰岛的不可思议的历史。
我好像看过这部
我帮你回忆一下
也给大家顺便介绍一下。
这个剧情
他的主人公
是一位预狱不得志的。
意大利工程师
有一天他突然蒙声了。
一个近乎一想天开的念头。
就是在离意大利不远的公海上面。
建立一座属于自己的岛。
成立一个不受任何国家。
管辖的国家
听着是不是很离谱。
但是更离谱的是
他居然真的开始做了。
他没有先去想说
这件事情一定会不会成功。
而是先去研究
能不能见
怎么见
需要什么材料
怎么把立竹运过去。
又怎么让他在海里立起来等等。
他就这样一步一步。
把一个别人眼里的幻想。
变成了现实
在建成之后
这个面积不大的小岛。
成为了很多小
脱离舒服的年轻人。
解放天性的地方
也成为了理想主义者。
抱团狂欢的误托邦。
当然就是在定
最后的结局
其实是没有这么的理想主义的。
这座岛还是被政府给炸毁了。
那从世俗意义上来讲。
可能算不上成功吧？
但我觉得他证明了一件事。
那就是很多事情
并不是因为一定会成功。
才值得去做
而是因为有人愿意相信。
他有可能
世界才会因此多了一种。
新的可能性
而且我想补充的
一点是
就是这个电影
他并不是虚构的
而是根据真实的
历史事件改编的
就是在半个多世纪之前。
真的有一位
叫做卓尔之尔的男人。
在海上建立了
一个玫瑰岛共和国。
那在2017年
就是在这个卓尔之尔。
他趋势的前夕
有一群来自意大利。
黎米尼地区的潜水园。
还特地潜入海底
从废墟中打捞了一块。
当年的废墟砖块
送给他
还写了一行字
是这样说的
黎米尼的潜水园
很荣幸
把梦的碎片
还给做梦的人
我觉得
卓尔之尔的世纪
放在聊
Sink Big的这一期。
真的太合适了
就是敢想敢做
他不在于说
想的是大还是小
而是当你思路打开。
付诸行动
世界总会以他的方式。
给到你英德的奖励。
你刚才说的时候
我想起来
最后扎倒那一部分了。
我也挺喜欢这部电影的。
就感觉他有一种
很认真
然后有很现实的
那种风感吧？
你看完会觉得好像。
所有伟大的事一开始。
都挺像在胡闹的
但不知怎么着
他就成了
那其实到
我们这一期的最后了。
我前面跟来西
在对提纲的时候
我们还在聊说
希望这期
我们就传达出一个。
怎样的信息
我记得我当时就说。
我认为 think big。
不是一个
可选项的思维
而是一个必选项的思维。
那我会认为
没有人真的是
希望自己的人生
是越火越窄的
那这里说的窄
不是说
见过多少世面呀？
去过多少地方
或者你取得了
多大的成就
而是你看待世界的方式。
理解世界的能力
去想象自己人生的空间。
有多少
那就像来西在开头说的。
我们小时候总觉得。
人生是有很多种可能的。
也可以成为很多种人。
可长大之后
我们反而是开始在。
不断地替自己
去删掉那些可能性的。
我最近读到的
一段话是来自
陈英翻译的意大利作家。
亚利山德罗巴里科的书。
叫《一个人消失在世上》
那这段话是这么写的。
贾斯伯格温教给我。
我们不是一些人物。
我们是故事
我们总是觉得自己是人物。
忙碌于冒险和日常生活。
但我们应该明白的是。
我们是整个故事
不仅仅是那些人物。
我们是那些
我们散布的树林
是骗人的坏蛋
是周围的混乱
是所有我们经历过的事情。
是东西的颜色
声音
您能懂吗？
那我想
如果就像这段话里面所说的。
如果我们不再把自己。
当做人物
而是当做一段故事的话。
或许我们就不会再。
去刻意限制自己了吧？
反而是会希望不断去增加。
自己这个故事的情节。
让它丰富一点
再丰富一点
好了
以上就是我们本期播客的全部内容。
感谢你的收听
期待你的订阅
接下来还有什么想听我们聊的。
欢迎随时留言
不论生活 史相何方。
我们一起另聘习近。